yeah Morgan my way I'm super pumped you
just did that I'd much rather just do QA
if you want to go right into that I'll
jam with you the whole [ __ ] time it's
good for people to start switching
because there's they don't have the
reporting to justify the ROI of spending
it in other places so what happens
Morgan is in both organizations the
cable companies the facebooks and the
other digital platforms and the CPGs
that completely subsidize all of this
and the car companies there's a
marketing head who has to justify all
their spend and there's historic rules
in place to what the ROI is in certain
arenas and when something new comes look
so for example every brand that is
trying to sell to somebody who is
between 20 and 30 years old should spend
a disproportionate amount of its money
in energy in 2015 on Instagram because
that's where 20 or 30 year olds are
giving their attention but nobody's
gonna be able to justify a
ten-million-dollar spend based on
getting 78 hearts on a [ __ ] picture
right and so what is happening what
always happens is first comes the market
facebook then comes the justification
right datalogix and all these other
things that play in my world that are
justifying the ROI of Facebook but
there's a friction Facebook was more
valuable to market 36 months ago than it
is today and it can be less valuable in
36 months because the number one thing I
know more than anything more than the
Sun comes up tomorrow is that marketers
ruin everything right I mean snapchat
hasn't even gotten at sea legs under it
and marketers are in there ruining it
right and so that's the constant game of
cat and mouse so Morgan the reason it
takes time is because companies aren't
entrepreneurial they're not making the
right decision for their business
they're making the right decision for
themselves a lot of people in this room
will go on to careers where they will
make decisions based on what's best for
them not what's best for the business
because they're not incentivized to act
that way
human behavior